НАТО готується відбивати ворожу атаку зі
сходу противник панує над частиною
Німеччини і хоче захопити Північний порт
Росток це легенда навчання Air Defender
2023 найбільших повітряних маневрів
Альянсу з моменту його заснування
навчання відбувається під проводом ФРН
я запропонував провести ці навчання ще у
2018 році після того як заступив на
посаду командувача ВПС Німеччини Це була
моя реакція на те що відбулося в Криму
коли Росія вдерлася в Крим Ми зрозуміли
що нам треба набагато більше
зосередитися на тому як захистити Альянс
25 держав понад 10 тисяч військових 250
літаків Сполучені Штати надсилають
стоповітряних суден Німеччини 70 швидка
передислокація винищувачів персоналу та
палива через атлантику важлива частина
маневрів
коли ми знаємо що американські солдати
можуть Буквально за лічені дні
передислокуватись сюди протягом 10 днів
це дає нам почуття безпеки що при
необхідності ми зможемо себе захистити
відбиття атаки Дронів і крилатих ракет
захист міст аеропортів та портів
евакуація мирних мешканців повітрям усе
це сценарії які прораховує і
відпрацьовує НАТО під час навчання у ВПС
Німеччини наголошують маневри не
спрямовані проти Росії від польотів у
бік Калінінграда організатори
відмовилися щоб не провокувати Москву
те що ці навчання необхідні стало
набагато ясніше зараз ніж коли вони
тільки планувалися після російського
вторгнення в Україну ми знаємо що
європейська безпекова архітектура якою
вона була протягом десятиліть більше не
працює і що оборонні потрібно надавати
на багато більшого значення
водночас експерти зазначають ідея
стримування Росії читається між рядків
навчання звісно надсилають сигнал вони
чітко демонструють що хоча цей
повітряний простір надзвичайно активно
використовується І зовсім невелике за
обсягом ми готові захищати кожен
сантиметр території натомів
значна увага до східного флангу НАТО під
час навчань винищувачі щодня літатимуть
до Естонії та Румунії а відтак і до
їхніх кордонів з Росією та Україною
повітряні сили США координуватимуться з
європейськими системами озброєнь
Німеччина Іспанія та Великобританія
надсилають винищувачі єврофайтер Греція
Туреччина та США надають f16 Угорщину
представляють винищувачі сааб-гріпен у
Південній Німеччині американські
бомбардувальники А 10 розміщені поруч із
найсучаснішим у світі винищувачем f-35
оснащеним технологією Stels щоб
приховати його від ворожих радарів
головна мета навчання європейське небо
має бути захищеним на всіх рівнях
протиповітряна оборона складається з
кількох елементів з одного боку це
наземна протиповітряна оборона вона
складається з радіолокаційних станцій і
зенітну артилерійських та
зенітно-ракетних засобів які знаходяться
на землі але звісно маневри
протиповітряної оборони також можуть
відбуватися виключно в повітрі наш літак
може боротися з ворожими літаками Ми
також можемо завдавати ударів з повітря
по засобах противника перш ніж він
матиме шанс атакувати нас ці параметри
повинні поєднуватися
Німеччина відіграє провідну роль у цих
навчаннях центр координації авіабаза
вунстор на заході Німеччини біля
ганновера тут найбільший склад
авіаційного палива в країні але основна
частина маневрів пройде на півночі ФРН
у програмі Air Defender 2023 передбачене
до заправлення літаків у повітря так
НАТО хоче показати що може захищати
європейське небо далеко за межами своєї
наземної оборони
ми маємо певні діапазони де можна
розташувати або розгорнути наші ракети
перехоплювачі це також дозволяє нам
досягти підрозділів морської піхоти та
військово-морських сил противника тому
що ворог може атакувати нас не лише з
суші
гідно з легендою навчань противник також
атакує з моря за допомогою військових
кораблів із-за підтримки винищувачів
поки в небі над Європою тривають
навчання цивільна авіація не зупиняється
попри те що Німеччина - це один із
найбільш завантажених повітряних
просторів у світі протягом 10 днів
навчань по черзі на кілька годин
закриватимуться трильотні зони над
Північною Німеччиною і північне морем на
сході і на півдні країни навчання
справжній виклик для німецьких
авіадиспетчерів цивільні та військові
диспетчери повинні навчитися постійно
координувати свої дії аби не скасовувати
цивільні рейси авіаційні експерти
впевнені що це цілком можливо
У нас є три великі льотні зони на
півночі на сході і на півдні У той
момент коли вони активуються всі
цивільні повітряні судна повинні оминати
ці зони і перебувати у тісній взаємодії
з потребами військових це може
спричинити затримки Так але це зовсім не
буде катастрофою
німецьке управління повітряним рухом
прогно
зує йому на 5-10 хвилин
при проведенні таких широкомасштабних
навчань як ці над Європою очевидно
цивільний літаки повинні будуть дати
дорогу військовим
почасоюзники по НАТО не хочуть зайвий
раз дратувати Росію масштабні навчання
все ж матимуть безпосередній ефект певні
аналітики російська Військова розвідка
буде змушена відволікатися на вивчення
авіаманеврів НАТО саме в той час коли
українська армія переходить у наступ
завдаючи дедалі більше ударів уздовж
лінії фронту на сході і півдні країни